leilani what brings you here tonight
well rounded guy wears many hats are
very impressed with people they could
just do that only acting but riding
producing
a leader no I'm not I just I'm not
organized like that okay but I'm
infamous with people that can and do and
have that vision and can put it all
together
to be very fun
what scene in the film or which actress
have you seen where you said you know
what I want to do that I want to do that
out I can tell you what you see in a
movie that I went okay maybe I should
not be an actress
I'm so impressed Oh God can you share it
or is it you know what Jennifer Aniston
always just comes to mind that she is so
such a leading lady type of
and yet she's so hilarious and funny and
that she has the capacity to really move
people in a kind of an everyday ordinary
way and really get to the heart of the
funny news a minute
about hard thing to do when you look as
gorgeous issues
she can it comes to mind
and lastly woods kryptonite for an actor
kryptonite
not to go right to the negative but
because it is such a hard profession and
and a lot of artists are so sensitive we
all are but artists I think more so and
that's what makes them great artists
what's what's the kryptonite for an
actor I think just having good this
strength to carry on because so many
times you're stopped at maybe not making
enough money to pay the bills or just
caring no so many times it's just
finding that inner strength and for me
it's family's life I have three children
and to me that is just where it's at for
me and it's really giving me this ring
for just carry on so that's my
kryptonite having a great family support
system very grounding when when you're
chasing after a toddler or something it
is although a minor in college high
school and elementary I wasn't thinking
that but okay Wow babies takraw laughter
but yeah it's been a very grounding
experience another
all right well thank you